I remember being in the team room on my
first day on the job it was a big team a
project lead with three Associates but I
of course compared myself to the other
associates in the room and for me when I
started the perceived difference between
me and all these associates was so
immense that I cannot even start to
describe it but they seem to be able to
do in their tools like Excel and
PowerPoint just was amazing they were
able to do everything three times four
times faster than I was able to do when
I started out and this for sure stressed
me out I quickly started to feel like a
false positive like an error in the
recruiting process the probably I just
kind of slipped through but actually if
they really did their homework right
they should never have hired me for this
job